good afternoon we'll open the work
session on a house a Senate bill 128.
relative to the payment for legal
services for persons involuntarily
admitted for mental health services
the
committee that this went to Judiciary
voted it out 17-3 was on the regular
calendar there was a floor amendment
that was offered that was defeated
by a vote of 182 to 201
and the house voted on the bill and the
house supported the bill by a vote of
as
the Senate
all right is there someone
here that's uh was one of the sponsors
that would like to speak to the bill
I see representative Lynn just itching
all right seeing nobody that sponsored
the bill will recognize representative
Lynn
to speak and I guess was this your the
amendment was something right that's
what I but the bill obviously came to us
from the Senate um and so at the as as
representative Smith indicated that
what's before you now is the bill
without any Amendment as as uh as
proposed by the Senate
um
and I guess I
I think the bill was uh was intended to
occur to uh to accomplish two things
I the first part I think is and I I you
know uh would ask representative Smith
when she speaks if she has a different
view but I don't think she does the
first part I think is really
um was sort of non-controversial in the
sense that the idea was to
transfer payment
uh uh from the Department of Health and
Human Services which although the
current law doesn't say
that it's the Department of Health and
Human Services that is supposed to pay
for these services at least it doesn't
say so in this statute now whether
there's some other statute that says
that that was never something that came
up but but this statute at least doesn't
say that it's supposed to be the
Department of Health and Human Services
that pays but that's been the practice
apparently for some time that they pay
for
um the services as I understand it and
the the idea of the of the Bill of that
part of the bill was to transfer that
responsibility to the judicial Council
which I think made sense since they pay
for services for Indigent Council in a
variety of contexts and you know why I I
mean why not why not consolidate that in
one place that that part I think seemed
to make sense
um I know uh Mr sample from the judicial
Council I think would have a might have
a view that if we were going to do that
maybe that requires some reallocation of
resources from the Department of Health
and Human Services to the judicial
Council and it and again if that's if
it's simply going to be sort of a
transfer that may make sense also the
second part of the bill
um is the part that
um that was the amendment was adopted
was directed to and that is that this
part of the Senate this aspect of the
Senate bill would eliminate the
responsibility of someone who is uh
appointed counsel in an involuntary
commitment proceeding whether it's the
temporary hearing the the so-called
three-day hearing
um that had the hearing has to be held
in three days or the more permanent one
that can result in a in a person being
involuntarily committed for a longer
period of time to to eliminate the
responsibility that a person has to if
if they're able to afford to uh to
reimburse the state that they do so
um that's the part that I had a real
problem I didn't understand since the
law has been that way since 1986.
um
uh you know on that point I guess my
quest really quite real question is what
has changed why should that should we
take that responsibility away uh that
has existed since 1986.
um you know that that went to the house
and I lost uh on on that side of it so I
guess that the question then that I
think the committee needs I would
suggest the committee needs to to
consider is
is it worth
is it work is it important enough to
change the payment responsibility from
the Department of Health and Human
Services to the uh judicial Council
that is is that worth
um uh giving up the responsibility of
someone who can who is able to afford to
reimburse the state the uh the imposing
upon that person the ability the
responsibility to do so and personally I
would say that it's not worth it and
that you uh if you know if if that's the
trade-off I would just my recommendation
would be simply to itl the bill or maybe
have some maybe retain it for some
further some further work on it but I I
just don't
um understand the changing that um
changing that responsibility the the
last thing I I know that representative
McGuire has talked about a proposal
member which I don't know whether he's
it says I don't know whether he's going
to offer or not but it's it's very
similar to the amendment that I offered
with one change and that is it would
remove
the responsibility of a person who could
afford to reimburse the state it would
remove that responsibility if the person
was not in fact involuntarily committed
and I guess what I would say about that
is I I
like that better than the Senate version
of the bill if it it's I I still have
one aspect of it but I do think it's an
improvement on the Senate version of the
bill because at least imposes or some
responsibility to repay the difficulty I
have with this and and I should say in
all fairness this would be consistent
with what the law is now with regard to
criminal cases if the if a defendant is
acquitted if defendant gets appointed
counsel and is acquitted the defendant
does not have the obligation to
reimburse the state that was adopted
about three years ago I think or four
years ago maybe that changed
the problem I have with with that
philosophy is it seems to me I mean in
some sense I I can understand the
argument of fairness well if you if you
were charged with a crime and you didn't
commit it or if you were if you were
involence committed and you and you
weren't really you know you shouldn't
have been involuntary committed why
should you have to pay for a lawyer
yeah I I get that on the other on the
other side of that is if you're charged
with a crime or you're involuntarily
committed and you are you know an upper
middle class or middle or maybe middle
class or upper middle class or a wealthy
person and you hire your own lawyer and
you're acquitted or you're not
involuntarily committed you don't get to
bill the state
for for the chart for your lawyers
charges even at the rate that uh you
know the lower rate that would be paid
for this so why why is that uh why is
that fair I guess I
um I don't think it is and so that's
that's my problem with that but you know
I'm I'm always one to never let the uh
the uh the perfect become the enemy of
the good and so I if if that Amendment
were offered
um it's I think it's an improvement on
the bill as it is right now
I'm happy to answer any questions for
represent McGuire Dan Maguire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um do we know how much money is changing
from one bill to the next I mean how
many cases are there where
um currently the person's paying on
their own and they're now going to be
paid by the state the you know that
that's well there's there is a fiscal
note which says that the total cost is
about 1.5 million dollars and I think my
understanding and I you know if they're
um if there's somebody who has more
information on the details of this then
they should test but my understanding is
that that 1.5 million is not just
for the Emergency admissions it's for
all
the admissions uh the emergency ones may
may very well be a large part of that
but but it's for all admissions in terms
of how many cases we did have
information on that
um
you know I want to say
a year I could be I somebody I just I've
forgotten off the top of my head but I
thought
okay something like that so um but you
know one of the things that we did not
receive any information on that I that
maybe there'll be somebody here that can
give you this information because I
think it would be important is
although we know that the Department of
Health and Human Services has a contract
and has been paid with some attorneys I
guess and has been paying these costs
one of the things that we don't know we
didn't receive any evidence on is what
effort the department has been making to
try to get reimbursement to or to find
out you know who is eligible who was
able to reimburse and who was not I
don't we don't have any information on
that and I think that would be something
that would be important
yeah um
would the under this procedure
um with the same attorneys just sort of
move over and get their check from the
judicial Council instead of HHS or is
they gonna have to find a whole new set
of attorneys who are inexperienced with
this
I would think if the if the if the only
thing that transfers is just you know
who the check is issued by I would think
that there would be not be a reason for
attorneys to you know to care and so
they would presumably continue but if
there's some maybe Mr sample could could
address that if there's some other
aspect that I'm not thinking about that
you know would make a difference in
attorney and an attorney's willingness
to to accept those cases that that that
that would be something he would have to
thank you Mr chairman
I'm puzzled by the um
the fiscal note
of the 10-year period between 2011 20-21
there was an average of
2449 iea cases filed in the Circuit
Court
that was and then on the the rest of it
it seems to act as if that is annual
rather than a 10-year that's like 60
people at 60 some people a day
I mean
it would make more sense if that total
would 10 years it's about 250 people a
year but to think this
2449 people a year in voluntary
admission I would believe it would be
for 10 years but 60 some people a day
right I that's that's a very good number
right
six people a day still that's more than
we have places to put them
Mr Hoffman any comments on the fiscal
note
2449 per year
over the 10-year period that sentence
could have been written a little bit
better
no wonder we're running out of places
because we don't have 2400 openings a
day a year rather
representative Carol McGuire did you
have a question
well while we're talking about the
fiscal note I would be interested in
they mentioned that the judicial Council
would need more people in more space and
my question is how much effort does the
HHS spend on managing this effort and
shouldn't those funds be moved along
official Council so they may be able to
answer that question okay representative
McGuire you got another question yeah
just to respond to representative Weiler
I was once on division three and well
twice and what I remember from the New
Hampshire hospital was that the average
length of stay was only 10 days
so it's surprising how short that is
because there's some people who live
there permanently right so so for
everybody else they basically are
committed they get their medications set
up and they leave you know so so it
isn't surprising to me that that there's
further questions for representative
Lynn representative Griffin well it's
kind of a general question I don't know
what the representative Lynn can answer
to someone else Kim
but I think pretty much the judicial
money comes out of the state budget and
I'm wondering whether the Health and
Human Services money comes out of the
federal budget
I do not know the answer to that
question
any further questions for representative
Lynn I I do have one so the financial
affidavit to determine whether someone
is able to pay this fee who chases that
down or someone doesn't fill it out
do you know the impact of that problem
right well you know that's why the
amendment both both the amendment that I
propose that failed and now
representative McGuire's is worded I
think pretty carefully it was designed
based upon my discussions with judge
king to see you know one of his points
was look very often it's the case that
so when somebody's brought in in in a in
a situation with it where there's
they're being sought to be involuntarily
admitted they're in a high state of
agitation and it's going to be very hard
to get them to fill out a financial
affidavit which is completely
understandable
um so I it was worded in a way to say
that that if if the if the court can't
get that information at the time it can
it should appoint counsel you know so
that's the that's the thing the right
thing to do and then refer the matter to
the uh to the office of Cost Containment
uh for them to conduct and and then you
know for them to get the person to fill
out the financial affidavit after the
back presumably after they've calmed
down and are in a better position to
provide that information and then on
that basis they can determine whether
the person uh is able to reimburse and I
and again I think that there may be
there may be a number of cases where the
person can't will not be able to
reimburse and they the the OCC would
then tell the court you know you should
just waive it because it's not it's not
worth it in this case to try to collect
so we like spending a hundred dollars to
try to get ten percent well I you know I
think that's what you know office and
Cost Containment that's something that
they do and they've been doing that in
the criminal context for a long time uh
they have some extra private I did talk
to Charlie arlinghaus in connection with
drafting the amendment
um and that that is something that they
have some expertise in and have been
doing for a while so you know if they I
think if they conclude
that it's not going to be worth it to
try to collect this money in this
particular case then they'll say they'll
tell the court that but
you know I think one of the things that
that I think
is is important to sort of think about
in this context is
I don't think we should have the
for lack of a better term this the sort
of you know discrimination of low
expectations that everybody that is
involved in one of these involuntarily
uh uh uh
emergency admissions is sort of you know
a person that uh is that's their life
they're going to be in this forever
they'll never be able to repay why are
we bothering to do that
um that kind of low expectation
maybe that's true for some subset of
them and maybe it's even a substantial
subset of of those people but I don't
think it's everyone and I don't think we
should be thinking in those terms maybe
there will be a subset of people who
will who have had you know a terrible
mental health uh trauma and will be
treated and get over it and when the
bill comes from the depart from the
office of Cost Containment they'll pay
the bill because they that's the right
thing to do and they'll and you know and
I don't think we should sort of assume
that that will not
be the case
representative Weiler
even though I screwed up the math
problem
since this does come to finance I'm
looking at the source of funds likely to
change I think you pointed that out
if we need to find out if somebody's
here from HHS what the percentages
that's paid is federal and state because
the judicial Council some of us know
always comes to fiscal
for their funds and those funds always
end up being General funds so are we
switching from maybe 50 percent
Federal 50 percent General to 100
percent
General funds that's something the
finance committee needs to weigh in on
seeing no further questions you're off
the hook for a few minutes but stay
around I will thank you
afternoon Mr chair good afternoon Mr
chair
um it is
well that's true I wasn't doing
everyone's title
I mean if I were going to really
acknowledge the most important people I
would be acknowledging Mr Hoffman
and I think all of you on the committee
would agree with me on that
um
I love the fact that I'm back here at
the finance committee where my heart has
always been and I know as you all know
that the finance committee does not get
involved in policy it never has it only
gets involved in the money and you'll
all with that blushing agree with that
um
I think there are a couple of points
that I would like to mention at the very
beginning
we are not talking here about anyone who
this is not a criminal proceeding
and I think we have to keep that in mind
if they need to be changes in criminal
proceeding let's do it in judiciary or
criminal justice but not in this bill
this is an involuntary
commitment
for a mental health crisis
I know and I think you all know
as you have gone over the budget and
looked at how Cost Containment works
that it frequently costs the state much
more per case
with all due respects for the
commissioner of administrative Services
costs the state much more to try to
collect
than what they receive
and that
for years there has been serious
discussion about whether in fact we
should be continuing the Cost
Containment effort because we're not
reaping the benefits that we should
and so I think you have to keep that in
mind
it's very very important
the person who is the principal here
is in a mental health crisis
they have not chosen
to ask the state to provide them with
mental health
Services they have not asked the state
to make expenditures on their behalf
they are
for reasons that are essential for their
well-being you know the well-being of
the community they are being
involuntarily committed
as far as the core part of the bill
that is
a given it is not at all
um changed in any way so what we're
talking about here
is who is going to pay
and the point that both
um
chairman Wyler and representative Dan
McGuire have made about where is this
money coming from
is an absolutely legitimate point is it
going to come out of the general fund or
is it going to come out of federal funds
um
and
if you look at
the fiscal note I think you will find
that unlike many fiscal notes this
fiscal note really isn't
very clear it doesn't give us the
information that we need to make an
informed decision
and
this room or the room across the hall
tomorrow is not the place to begin to
change the policy of what we're going to
be doing with involuntary
uh
commitments
if I had my druthers and I'm not on
finance much to my
sadness although it does mean that I can
be with my current chair and that's been
delightful we've done very well together
I believe
um it would be to either
pass the Senate bill as it came
from the Senate to the house and from
the house to the finance committee
because that's what it is or
itl the bill and say we're just going to
leave things
the way they are and in time find the
kind of information we need to make an
informed
decision
um
and uh
I I that to me just seems to be the most
responsible thing that you can do now
there are people here
who unlike me who just get I'm a gadfly
in this you know I sit in the
legislature and I make these
pronouncements there are people who
actually do the work
and you know and they're sitting behind
me and they might have a very different
view of it
but
we have a severe problem in this state
and we all agree
with mental health
and it's not just in this state it's
across the country with mental health
crises we're talking about a mental
health crisis in this
um and uh
I this isn't the time I I have no no
standing all the representative McGuire
was kind enough to share his
Amendment
um with me he is not introducing so
obviously I can't talk about it now but
if you were to look at it seriously I
would love to be able to come back and
address a couple of points in that but
meanwhile
um I think you can either
score some
points with the Senate and say okay
we'll accept the Senate version and then
that gives you the opportunity to say
okay we accepted the Senate version on
this so now you have to think about
where you're going to accept the house
version I'm just saying that chairman
Weiler I mean you might not want to
follow that
um
or
itl the bill and just keep things the
way they are and have a more
well as a former chair of Finance knows
that those of us that are still here on
finance are kind of unruly Bunch
including chairman Weiler so we'll try
to do what's best thank you very much
but when I was chaired the group was not
unruly and you of all people should know
that Mr chair
no I do recall you coming to the door
many times Madam chair so uh
representative evil has a question
aren't uh
vacuum and Senator Abbas was the Prime
sponsor for this
um do you know from testimony that you
received in the Judiciary Committee
whether the change in um
payment responsibilities was motivated
in this bill from the policy side or
precisely because I do know the answer
to that because I have been told the
answer and that is that the court
asked for the change they'd rather it
was and made it more clear to them if it
went through the judicial Council
so because that makes perfect sense to
me but the the portion of it where the
requirement for the folks that are
involuntarily committed to be basically
waived what was the was that also from
the quarter what was the Genesis of that
my understanding is that the bill
was drafted according to what the court
wanted but we all know many is the slip
representative Griffin
so
representative you presented two options
is there a third we have a lot of
unanswered questions
that we need to know where the money's
coming from can we retain the bill we
get the answers those questions
um retain is is certainly
any further questions for representative
Smith I do like the idea representative
all right thank you representative Smith
someone from the judicial Council would
you like to
speak and if you state your name for the
good afternoon my name is Richard Sam
Peril I'm the acting executive director
of the New Hampshire judicial Council
um
so I've learned a little bit about the
process throughout the course of the
prior hearings and about the payment
process but
um I'll tell you sort of from the
judicial council's perspective what the
concerns are here
one is if this responsibility is
transferred to the judicial Council
there's currently nothing in our budget
or our proposed budget in terms of
payment for this particular line of
services
so we would be in the position of having
to go back to fiscal and ask for an
additional appropriation to make these
payments
then we get to the issue of how much to
ask for and
um I think that amount is a bit murky
because the fiscal note includes
information from Health and Human
Services that has an estimate for what
they have paid which is nine hundred
thousand dollars uh annually and then
the judicial branch keeps data on their
website as to the number of involuntary
admissions that take place in a given
year that's the data I used in my
interpretation of what the cost would be
I should say that that applies to both
involuntary emergency Admissions and to
non-emergency admissions so all forms of
uh commitment whether they're emergency
or not but it would be an additional
basically 2500 invoices that we would be
paying a year I I don't think that's a
huge amount but it is sort of for our
agency because of how small we are it's
me and then it's two staff members that
process all of the the bills so uh the
volume of those additional
responsibilities is a concern in
addition to that we've only been talking
about paying for the lawyers but the
legislation would also transfer the
responsibility for services in addition
to lawyers again I don't know
practically speaking how often that
comes up but it would impose an
obligation to pay for expert Witnesses
or anything else like that
um and then in terms of the actual cost
um so my understanding is that the
judicial branch has a contract with
certain lawyers to provide these Legal
Services it pays them a flat rate that's
the minimum amount that's in the fiscal
node but the court also has a rule that
establishes a maximum potential payment
in these cases that's the maximum amount
that that's how uh I got to the amount
that's listed there as uh almost 1.5
million
so that would be the monetary amount we
would be talking about there I do have
one other additional concern I want to
address with you which is the collection
part of it and there
um I I will admit I'm confused about
what the process would be the mechanics
of collection these hearings are
typically sort of one and done with the
court and the concern I would have is
that because this is a population that
perhaps doesn't always have a reliable
housing address information maybe is a
little less reliable in showing up for
court appearances or making contact with
office of Cost Containment that we're
turning a
half hour hearing on a one given date
into a multi-hearing event and now we're
paying for lawyers on successifications
again I don't know practically speaking
how that works now but I do have that
concern when I hear the conversation
about OCC and collection uh for the
legal services from this particular type
of population
those are my thoughts on this I'm happy
to answer any questions
seeing that you wish to take questions
representative Carol McGuire
actually it's it's more to you Mr chair
the house
uh did rejected that amendment to
require repayment and Cost Containment
and therefore we should not be
considering it
because the house position is that and
the Senate position is that the the
state or some other source of funds will
pay for these lawyers and Recovery is
not on the table as far as I'm concerned
no we're just looking at the bills that
came to us from the Senate and as it was
approved by the house without the
amendment right and
[Music]
from the physical
that um
all funds involved are General funds
thank you
thanks for pointing it out I can I
address what little information I have
about the source of funding
um my belief is that there this is
generally paid out of General funds uh
out of state funds I do think the
judicial branch in terms of what they've
been paying that they may have received
a small amount of arpa money and so if
this responsibility was transferred we
would ask them to transfer that but I
don't think that is a long-term payment
uh I don't think the federal government
is a long-term payment source for this
thank you seeing no further questions
I'll representative Dan McGuire thank
you do you know much about the mechanics
of how these cases are processed we've
heard that there's about a half dozen a
day is that you know one judge and one
attorney traveled to the state hospital
and setups you know six in a row for an
hour or two and and just do it or is it
six different attorneys and all that do
you know
um so
the answer is I don't but I do know a
little and in my belief is that uh on a
given day a lot of these hearings are
not all in person Summer by video that a
lawyer who contracts with the judicial
branches
representing people on a given day but
that they have a designated judge going
through and doing these hearings but
again I say that with the caveat that I
I don't have any personal experience
with these times kinds of hearings and I
don't have a good understanding of the
quickly
if you could take the mic please
thanks
there's a very strict time limit
um in terms of how long you can wait
until you have this trial
um I mean this procedure it's really not
a trial
um and it's the first thing that a judge
has to do when he comes in on a Monday
morning or she comes in on a Monday
morning and it is
almost never done in person
and the attorney gets we haven't
mentioned this yet the attorney gets a
hundred dollars
and
um
the case is made and the judge rules and
was that short enough it was thank you
certainly
representative Senator Griffin as you
like to offer a motion I heard something
earlier
I'm happy to make a motion we retain
this bill for further study
emotions been made by representative
Griffin to retain seconded by
representative Weiler is any further
questions comments seeing none when the
clerk is ready if you'd please call the
roll
okay so the motion is to retain SB 128
representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative oh I'm hatch evil uh yes
okay Hewitt absent and then uh
yes
absences
yeah
the vote being H is zero to retain the
bill will be retained there'll be no
okay
okay moving to um our 130 bill Senate
bill 204.
to be available in state-owned buildings
commissioner arlinghaus I see you here
so I assume you were here to speak to
this
Senate Bill I'm here to do whatever you
want
I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of administrative Services
Karen rantamaki director of plant and
property
would you like to speak briefly since it
I guess it really affects you more than
anybody else so the um so the couple
things it's uh trauma kits not first aid
kits we had a couple of discussions with
Senator Apprentice about this
um over time and uh I know her vision is
lots of kits and lots of buildings
and we had discussions about you know
which buildings count as buildings and
buildings is one of those questions if
you ask the question how many buildings
does the state have
um the answer is depends what you mean
and um you know is it 91 is it 216 or is
it a thousand and four and
um you know the energy database has one
number and all of that I think based on
what she wanted to do we came to the
conclusion that for the first tranche of
what she wants to do there are about 200
buildings
I don't do you remember the derivation
of that
so we decided to exclude hospitals and
institutions under the assumption that
they would already have similar type
equipment on hand also things like salt
sheds anything where there's people that
aren't in those buildings and that's
where we came up to the uh came up with
the two to three hundred range of
buildings where we we would be
just for a little history I got ahead of
myself just so the committee knows this
did pass Edna unanimously 16-0 and there
was a Voice vote and it passed on the
house floor in a Voice vote
so representative Dan McGuire you had a
question yes did you include liquor
stores
I believe we did include liquor stores
yes
representative grass I know you
mentioned you took out salt sheds and
other places where people are present
but having worked in the field
um that's some place where people tend
to be injured
uh because they're in and out of
vehicles and they're they're working
with heavy equipment in those locations
uh do you have any idea of how many
additional locations those would it
would include
as Charlie mentioned earlier
um somewhere around a thousand buildings
is the number of buildings we track in
our energy database for buildings that
use energy so that could be anything
from a small restroom building at a
state park to a salt shed to a hospital
or a correctional facility so somewhere
in that range where we said you know two
to three hundred up to a thousand would
be you know depending on how far you
want to go I could get you some more
detailed breakdown of what types of
facilities those are if if that would be
something of Interest
I think Senator princess came up with
the with the number like the 220 in in
trying to
figure out a reasonable range for first
implementation that included
you know not every storage building but
every building which you know got us the
sort of the biggest bang for the this
would be the best 200 or so to do and it
doesn't mean that you know that that you
know every building at the park and in a
park is not suitable or people at parks
all the time but how about these and not
these and I think there's a provision in
the bill something about having the
department or the fire safety fire
standards or someone like that decide
which buildings on the assumption that
they're the
they're better at trauma than the rest
of us
I would just be concerned about
particularly in public works I know that
salt sheds a lot of times not moving
equipment around as much but it
certainly is something Whenever there is
heavy equipment involved there's always
the chance for an injury and uh so
that's something that we should be
concerned about
further questions uh representative
Weiler
another concern of course would be a
storage building or a salt shed if it's
if it's unoccupied
and there's nobody there with the
training or even could tell them where
it was it's not much use and it's likely
to be either taken or or you know
misused if it's just left in an
unoccupied empty building so I think you
have to have people available people in
the building some idea where it is and
not leaving it just kind of where
anybody can grab it I think we would try
to follow the kind of standards that you
know that a lot of buildings now have
and have an AED a AED AED
um and uh follow those kind of Standards
where you want you want them to be uh
somewhat secure and not just you know
readily available but also somewhat
secure and that's
a balancing act that I'm pretty sure we
could probably accomplish
representative Dia Maguire fire followed
by representative Griffin thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um let's talk about the money aspects of
this so this bill doesn't actually
allocate any money to purchase this it
sets up a dedicated fund but doesn't put
any money into it now in general does
your department keep separate dedicated
funds for different aspects of you know
do you have the the desk fund and the
chair fund and the you know the first
aid kit fund like that or or do you just
sort of buy these things in bulk well so
from an accounting standpoint we you
know dedicated funds are a thing in the
budget and if you've had The Misfortune
to be on that committee at any point
um that's you know that's the thing and
and that whole process and the book
that's published every year in addition
to that though we routinely allocate
everything we spend you know you can't
spend a dime without it coming out of a
specific accounting unit a specific
class line and if we were to receive
gifts for trauma kits it's not
problematic without there being a
dedicated fund for us to make sure that
the money is spent on trauma kits and to
track that because it would be done
through just class lines and activity
codes so that's not really it's not
really an issue but you could do it
without being a dedicated dedicated fund
it could just be
earmarked so to speak at the department
for this purpose and we would use it for
that purpose it's something that we
typically typically do
although we don't often receive
donations
it's not we're not a 1c3 yeah
thank you so
um
all right so that explains and and is I
communicated with Senator Prentiss and
she told me she thought the reason she
put in the dedicated fund was she
thought that was necessary for gifts and
grants which it isn't so all right the
second thing is the having some money to
get this going right
um do you think that roughly fifty
thousand dollars would be suitable for
I I would think so the you know my
understanding from the good Senator is
that trauma kits are relatively you know
they're a lot more complicated than than
a first aid kit which is you know 20 40
50 bucks but they're not so much more
complicated that a decent trauma kid of
the kind she foresees is dramatically
expensive and we certainly could and
like anything else that we do we spend
money within funds appropriated and we
every day every decision Karen makes
every day involves triage
and so that's what we would be doing
representative Griffin followed by
representative Carol McGuire
when I when I first saw this ballet
said to myself wow that's a great idea
what I immediately said
why why do we have to pass a state law
to do this
why can't we do it administratively and
then I read the section about limited
liability for anyone using the trauma
kit but I think probably a good
Samaritan laws cover that anyway
and then I thought about well what
happens if there's a case in the LLB and
someone goes for the trauma kit and it's
not there
then we have a we have a real liability
so
I'm not really in favor of making this a
state law I am in favor
of drama kits in in the most of the
buildings the Occupy buildings of a
state but I don't see why it can't be
done administratively
or money put in the budget for it so it
can be done administratively without
passing a separate law
I don't think we have an opinion on that
represent Carol McGuire yeah yes thank
you Mr chair from what I remember from
dealing with this in Edna
the total amount of money we figured for
the first group was something less than
ten thousand dollars
because there's a truck 200 buildings a
couple of hundred dollars for trauma kit
you know you're talking five ten
thousand dollars
it's not a big deal and I and I agree I
think that the cost of maintaining the
dedicated fund would
be wasted for the amount of gifts and
grants you'd be getting for this
um I agree with representative Griffin
that this would be better to uh
advise the building managers that you
know you've got a lot of people coming
through you might want to have a have a
a trauma kit as well as your AED and
your first aid kit
because we thought we were thinking of
accidents like in public works or in the
liquor store but on further research
these are mostly for gunshot wounds
we haven't had a gunshot case in the LLB
that I know of
for a few years at least
but you know
and and
I think just being ready for it is uh
like representative Griffin said we can
uh commissioner what's been said seems
to make a lot of sense because if you go
to somewhere you have an eye wash for
instance I don't think someone had to
come to the legislature to say you know
we really should have an eye wash here
in this particular room because their
handling hazardous materials is that a
good subjects and rules usually yeah I
think that's perfectly fair I don't I
don't have a dog in this fight so to
speak do you give us money for trauma
kids will spend it on trauma kits if you
don't give us money for trauma kids we
representative evil followed by
representative Griffin thank you so I
also talked to Senator Prentice and I
got her testimony that she submitted and
it says here that the kits run from 23
to 83 dollars a piece and although their
service can be Priceless the thing that
really struck me is she said in the
state of New Hampshire bleed outs are
the third highest
um
third highest cause of death and in the
U.S it's like fourth it's preventative
death and I guess my
my concern would be yes we can tell you
that you should have them but unless
there's something that requires you to
have them and there's not specific
funding you might not and this seemed
like such a simple logical thing to me I
came to the different conclusion I
thought that it was a good idea and also
we're at the very end of the road here
and from a policy perspective the the
house did pass it and it was recommended
okay it was just informed that
representative Dan McGuire has an
amendment that may fix some of these
had a chance to take a quick look and
ask representative Deanne McGuire to
speak to his Amendment please
thank you Mr chairman so
um this is a replace all so it should be
relatively easy to read
um
it does three things compared to the
original bill
so
um number one it at it it removes the
dedicated fund
then it allocates fifty thousand dollars
for this purpose now if it turns out 50
is too much and it should be 20
I assume the Das doesn't have to spend
every last dollar
allocated right they might have a lapse
that they might appreciate anyway so
um
but and there might be some installation
type costs right you might have to put a
hook on the wall and a sign and who
knows what or a box or signs in the
elevators yeah
so there might be other costs besides
the The Bare Bones cost of the kit
itself enter and also distribution and
the other thing it did was the original
bill created a um Committee of EMTs and
told them to come up with a list of
places and so on and so that seemed like
Overkill to me so I
um replaced the committee with saying
Das should perform this and they should
consult with the EMTs
um just in terms of what kit to buy and
and things like that so so it made it a
little less less
complicated I think
questions for representative Dan McGuire
um I like
I like your uh Amendment but I'm still
concerned about
a trauma kit shall be installed and
readily available in in state-owned
buildings
as a general thing with it needs to be
really narrowed down to
to uh
designated by somebody or whatever
state-owned buildings we've heard this
doesn't spawn how you want to count them
when there's a hundred uh
a thousand
and and that opens up to liability when
someone gets there it and there's no
trauma get in the building
so I I think it's great to raise the
money
you know I still think probably we
should retain this thing and work on it
and raise the money so Charlie has the
money to
put them out where it makes sense
you know the buildings are occupied or
remember
yeah so that line is unchanged from the
original bill it does not say all
state-owned buildings right so
you know
uh representative evil fall by represent
grassy
five the most needy buildings that that
concern of all state buildings has been
Mr chairman I said two things I I might
add or least because if we want the
liquor stores they're all leased and I
believe the chief here can answer some
more technical questions if you have
them about
emsc sort of things
or if you could take a seat please and
state your name for the record surely um
Justin mom chief of the Bureau of Ems
for the state I work for the division of
fire standards and training I believe
the original mindset was kind of like a
crawl walk run so the reason why it was
state owned and occupied buildings was
that these are Public Access kits
although they they certainly could
benefit in some of the
um you know the public work areas but it
was for Public Access
as Senator Prentice mentioned in her
testimony you know bleeding out is a um
is something that could be corrected
pretty easily with these kits um with
quick action
um and so the mindset is to get more of
these kits out there starting small with
uh state-owned buildings and state
occupied buildings
um training uh is minimal our e901 so
our Dispatch Center anytime somebody
calls 9-1-1 they get one Center in the
state of New Hampshire those individuals
that are taking that call can direct
somebody on how to put a tourniquet on
through the phone uh it's very easy and
I believe the original Amendment the
reason why or the original bill is the
reason why they had some of the language
in there for protection was for just
that liability is that if somebody were
to use these similar to how nalox
cylinders separate
liability protections and that sort of
thing
um as far as cost you know there's a
range based on what where what Senate
Apprentice was requiring in the kit
there's different
um options to fulfill the different
requirements and that's why there's a
range
um and the mindset to add
members of the division my division I'm
sorry my Bureau as well as one of our
boards that our advisory boards was to
have the same folks that are overseeing
the EMS in the state the entire EMS
system also to have guidance on on this
with the sole regulatory of EMS in this
state we advise our providers on what
equipment they should have what they
shouldn't have and so I believe the
senator thought that that was made sense
questions representative Weiler thank
you Mr chairman when I first read the
bill I was picturing these kits with the
batteries in them that shocked the heart
when it stops and I guess they were
quite a bit more expensive and I guess
that's not the intent of the bill so
so we do have a Statewide
bid for aeds in the state and so what
that means is any business has the
ability to purchase an AED at a reduced
price and that'll also the Only Rule
requirement is that it's registered
within the state the benefit of that is
that when somebody calls 9-1-1 the 911
operator is able to direct somebody to
the closest AED
there is a mechanism that that this
could be done for bleeding kids down the
road that isn't part of this but that's
ultimately nationally that's the mindset
the two things we could prevent is
bleeding out and quick access to
electricity AED is going to correct the
abnormal Rhythm and again it's easy
things that anybody can do to to Really
representative evil thank you
my first question is really boring could
you give me your name please certainly
okay and then the second one could you
um just clarify the product the
professional credentials of Senator
Prentice because she clearly knows where
of she speaks surely um so she she had
my position a few years back um so she
was a former Chief of the Bureau of EMS
she is I believe she's now the director
of the American trauma uh
Services
a trauma society and she is also a
paramedic and still an active paramedic
which is the highest level pre-hospital
providering
search here just all I would just add is
that I did speak to her and I know
representative McGuire did too and she
was very passionate about this and she
said that this was a really simple way
of saving many lives and she was really
hopeful that the bill could go forward
and she's not here by the way because of
her job she had to travel to Washington
D.C
see no further questions for you you're
okay we do have an amendment before us I
agree with several that have spoken that
makes a number of good improvements
representative dear Maguire well the one
thing we've heard in this testimony is
that maybe after state-owned we should
add and state occupied
so that that way at least buildings that
[Laughter]
because it may be the owner of the
building that's responsible for
providing certain things versus it being
a mandate from the state because the
state doesn't own their particular
buildings
but it doesn't hurt right a trauma kit
shall be installed and ready readily
available in selected state-owned and
state-occupied buildings
representable
Pacific
speaking as a lawyer
representative Sweeney thank you I I
think I understand where the issue comes
because the way I would read a trauma
kit shall be installed and readily
available in state-owned buildings that
sentence right there feels like the
requirement is for every state-owned
building so I do think so adding in the
either pursuant to or just the language
of in selected state-owned and or
occupied buildings clears it up that
it's not every
well I think you could say identified
pursuant to section blah blah blah or
something
it just makes it really clear
come on Dan
I think in general when when you have
sorry when you have a whole section you
don't have to say in section one see
section three right it's all part of the
part yeah all right so
um hopefully we can get that if the
division supports well let's have a
little show of hands with the corrected
language and the representative Deanne
McGuire we all okay with that
okay so um
Dan if you could get that ready for us
well there's a 50 000 do you want to
speak
okay I I'm okay with that but
uh representative Sweeney do you have
just one question with these and this
sort of with the Senate bills that we do
have
they put it in their version of the
budget
or is this
Mr Hoffman
I believe that
okay representative Griffin had a
question
oh yes yeah so
um
so I figured 250 buildings times two
hundred dollars that's that's fifty
thousand right so you know the there's
the kit but there may be some ancillary
costs so that's kind of where it came
from can I just ask if they have to
re-replace if they're used I mean how
does that work like is there an
expiration date like are they only good
for a couple of years no matter whether
they're used or not do they have to be
replaced like fall kits I know that you
have to be replacing like five years
foreign
all right so uh we did ever show a hands
on the McGuire Amendment which passed
unanimously now we'll vote on the bill
as amended when the clerk is ready to
call though I'll do a much better
amendment number
um it's currently
2064 H but obviously that's going to
okay
um so we're voting on SB 204
otpa and representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin representative
Sweeney yes representative Carol McGuire
representative grassy yes
clerk votes yes chair Weiler yes
okay
eight zero and chair I said
representative Wyler he said yes I
didn't oh and chair Leachman well that's
fine yes okay but I was so excited I had
eight nothing yeah
I'm gonna get fired okay so thank you
so we have one more we'll try to get
through this quickly as well Senate bill
267.
requiring the commissioner of the
Department of Environmental Services to
consider cumulative impacts analysis and
rules and statutes
um yes the good senator from District 24
right
um
thank you representative
um I
um I have come to
clarify any questions you may have about
this bill
um it's Genesis and how it ended up
where it is
the change that you see between the
Senate Bill the amended Senate bill and
the house bill is a deepening of the
reporting
um the Senate bill
if you go to your amendment by the house
the addition
of the house environment and
agricultural committee has been added
um and uh our deepest apologies for not
including in the Senate Bill we had
originally only reported out to house
resources Recreation and development
and natural resources committee so this
is a third committee that should that
should absolutely receive this report on
findings of cumulative impacts I'd just
like to point out to the division this
did pass out of the environment and
agriculture committee 19-0 yes and on
um so the appropriation I think is a
hundred and fifty thousand I believe
unless that was also amended I don't
210 on the newest oh do I have the wrong
there it is yes Senator I think I think
23 oh yes you did
okay
questions for the good Senator
Senator can you um tell us what
uh time impact this is likely to have on
people
um well it actually
isn't it doesn't impact them at all
right now
um
what you may have heard in the for if
um and there was a time impact that has
been stripped out and now we have uh per
our conversations with the Department of
uh energy
and
um invite I'm sorry with the Department
of Environmental Services is that they
um would like to put
some serious effort into doing this
which is why you see I see the thank you
for the the redone
um the 123 000
expenditure is for Staffing so that this
person might be able to put an actual
formula together if you will and we have
input from our neighboring states who
have already begun to do this kind of
work so we are not Reinventing the wheel
we are putting we are using a template
that has been used successfully in other
places but the impact of this data which
we do collect but only for individual
sites so the change that this will make
is that when someone goes to permit
what we are looking to assess is right
now permitting exists in The Silo of the
space of the permit and the type of
permit being asked for it does not take
into account
what may also be within the neighborhood
so if you're looking at a an industrial
park it matters what the neighbor's
doing right because you what you do
could have impact on the neighbor and
vice versa so assessing what those
cumulative impacts could be
is what the nature of this bill is about
is to assess what they are how are we
going to measure them how are we going
to report them out and how will we
potentially
Implement that into future rules or
legislation nothing that impacts what's
happening right now and as of right now
we don't have any outstanding
applications
so there's it wouldn't be affecting
anyone who has something in the works
right now because there isn't anything
representative Thank You by Carol
McGuire thank you man Mr chairman thank
you senator for coming
um what does the word facilities mean in
this context is this energy generation
tell me exactly where you are
um oh proposal for example proposed
facility
right um so proposed facilities
um any any proposed facility that would
have to seek out in their current
permitting
um would have to have an assessment of
potential
um air pollution potential groundwater
pollution like what we do now for
individual sites that we do we do this
now so we we assess what happens within
one particular site what we don't take
into account is how that site affects
the site next to it Downstream from it
up upwind from it this
would start to look at the accumulation
of that
hence cumulative impacts yeah so uh
is a facility could be an apartment
building no no we're talking about
um
potentially energy energy facilities
waste facilities
that type of facility manufacturing
facilities
apartment buildings okay don't generate
I don't know what's in the mall
I I couldn't answer that because as part
of the permitting would they have a
manufacturing site would they have would
they be generating you know air
pollution I don't know thank you yeah
thank you
representative Carol McGuire and then we
um this would be great because we have
been through we've all been on a journey
together yeah if you could
restate your name for yes the record uh
just for the record my name is Craig
Wright I serve as the Director of the
air Resources Division at the Department
of Environmental Services thank you
Carol thank you Mr chair I'm Senator I
find it impossible to believe you when
you say there is nobody who is has
currently applied for a permit that is
waiting for it to be approved I mean
every restaurant
and anybody dealing with Wastewater
needs a permit
and so as what I mean air facilities yes
there's very few but water
everybody has water if you want Mr chair
I can try to address that to some degree
so obviously the department has a number
of different regulatory programs and we
require permits for all kinds of either
industrial facilities wastewater
treatment plants
there could be requirements for Air
permits water permits waste permits yes
there is currently a queue of people
waiting to get their permits and we're
going through our normal review process
not to contradict you but but I think I
I think what really what the question is
is what this bill does is it asks the
department to go out and investigate do
a scoping study
on ways to look at cumulative impacts
across air water and waste I agree with
the senator right now it would have no
impact on facilities currently in the
queue because this is a scoping study to
come up with either potential new
regulations or statutes we need to
address in the future
to address cumulative impacts
follow-up representative McGuire yes
thank you I it
I I don't know much about the water
rules but the the waste I don't mean I
don't know about the air rules the waste
of the water rules I know affect a whole
lot of people in the state between the
people on Wetlands or lakes or protected
Rivers
or needing a thousand gallons grease
trap for a for an ice cream shack I mean
there are lots and lots of rules already
and
I agree this this in itself may not
cause any delays but I'm
I'm very concerned that adding in the
fact that the
restaurant next to you also has a grease
trap
or a sewer system or you're
or some neighbor at your lake house
could affect a lot of people if you
decide to
become much more rigorous in in
enforcing the laws because of cumulative
impact
representative Weiler please
thank you Mr chair having been on a
planning board for many years I think
it's overly broad it
will likely cause nothing to be
developed there'll be always be somebody
to complain about ever that planning
board somebody complains from a mile
away the effect of something it's going
to have on them and the the explanation
was kind of spurious I felt
um and I've had had someone else send me
a thing this never ends everything is
going to be objected to and it's going
to be dragged through court and I'd hate
to
enable the people that come in with
spurious complaints to claim they're
covered by law
I
it's it's just too broad I don't think I
don't think I could vote for this
it just leaves everything
is affecting somebody that's that's the
way it comes out
representative Griffin followed by
representative grassy yeah I uh
I probably was one of those 77 that
voted no and I was sure and I intend to
representative grassy and followed by
representative evil having worked in the
field with development and as a town
planner for 20 years
um I think that you know first of all we
already have projects of regional impact
which we take a look at accumulative
effects from Regional impact that the
planning the planning commissions work
on and I think that this is something
that's very good because you know a lot
of times when we're looking at a project
at a planning board level we're looking
at the project
you don't look at anything outside of
the boundaries except when we take a
look at traffic impacts a lot of times
we'll have Regional traffic impact
studies done to show what the impact of
traffic will be when we take a look at
other services outside Services
sometimes we take a look at what
recreational Services may be to service
a residential project when you're
looking at industrial projects and even
residential projects that where you may
or may not have Municipal Sewer and
Water Systems you're taking a look at
the impacts on the aquifers and other
things so you know there's certainly a
lot here I'm not fully understanding
what the impacts are here I mean how
you're going to you know what are you
going to be looking at and how this is
going to affect individual projects
in the you know when we deal with an
image original project are you looking
at basically
using this law to start looking at
ways to to
um
so when I bring in a product a project
comes into my planning board and I call
you and I say what are the water impacts
this is what we're going to have for
septic loading on this site what are
going to be the water impacts on the
aquifer that this sets on
is this going to help you determine
what's around that project so you're
going to give me that information as
well because I don't have that
information when I'm looking at an
individual project and you know when I
look at runoff when I look at septic I
know you're an air guy but I understand
the problems with air as well having
dealt with some of those projects but
are you going to be is this going to
um I just want to clarify for the
committee that the cumulative impact
analysis portion of this
um is is to take into consideration
there is nothing right now there's no
legislation proposed there is no
legislation written there is nothing
waiting what we are looking for is for
Des to have staff dedicated to be able
to find out what cumulative impacts
means to New Hampshire and what the
combined impacts of proposed facilities
that may be putting out potential air
pollution what we're not assessing right
now is what goes up comes down and how
does that affect the water table we
don't look at that right now we don't do
that at all that is not something that
happens for regional planning
we only do this for site specific so we
are looking to broaden our look because
we know particularly on the Seacoast we
know that once you damage the water
table you then damage your agricultural
um
industry we have Farms that have been
directly impacted by water pollution
that's a cumulative impact because that
then that affects our our Industries it
affects our businesses so what we need
to do is to look at cumulative impacts
with a public health lens as well so we
would like to afford Des the opportunity
as passed in policy already
the 247 thousand dollars 123 in the
first year 124 in the second year to
dedicate to a person to be able to do
this work and I think you had some
additions so yeah I just I would just
add
um
so cumulative impacts is a term that is
I would say is not
totally clearly defined anywhere either
in state rule state law
or in federal rule or federal law
the environments in which I get
questions about cumulative impact either
occur from the public concerns about
what is the impact of
this facility in addition to this
facility or this air toxic in addition
to this air toxic
the other place we hear it all the time
is coming out of EPA in the federal
government
it's high in their agenda they've tied
it largely into the Civil Rights Act of
1964 in a term that they call
environmental justice
so EPA continues pushing states to look
at cumulative impacts without an
existing regulatory framework
if you're asking me what we would do if
this bill were passed we couldn't do
this work without the position I I know
I can tell you that wholeheartedly
the things we would do is and again and
this is up the ultimate end goal is
within two years approximately by
September of 2025 is to report back to
the legislature on recommendations from
the Department things we would do is
survey what's being done in other states
and what's being done at the federal
level
um we would probably establish some sort
of internal work group across the air
the division the Water Division and the
waste Division and look at where our
programs intersect in ways in which we
could look at the impacts from each of
our programs as they piggyback on top of
each other we would need to consult with
an in-house toxicologist which is a
which is already in-house existing
position to better understand how
cumulative impacts occur when you have
different pollutants different Pathways
of exposure and we need to consult with
Community groups I think to determine
what is the concern of the citizenry of
New Hampshire and ultimately prepare
recommendations and report for the
legislative General Court
thank you represent grassy followed by
so from what I understand from what you
just said as a town planner and as a
town planning board remember this is or
a developer in the community this is
going to affect me at all and then over
the next couple years you're looking at
setting up getting gaining information
yourself in within your departments and
within Des it's not going to have any
effect on me right now but it could in
the long term provide me more
information absolutely but it's not
going to slow down any of my projects
not right now I mean it's a scoping
study right now with recommendations to
how Des would have to potentially change
it's either statutes that govern Des or
our administrative rules which all go
through public processes so you're
saying it's better to be prepared than
be caught when Des comes down and says
you have to do this stuff and we're in
no we haven't done anything I would say
if it's the desire of the legislature
for us to consider cumulative impacts in
our programs then we need to look at it
and do a study that's that's really all
I'm saying
representative of you both followed by
representative Sweeney
um I just want to understand the
background of this bill did this bill
not start out originally as a bill that
would have required regulations to be
written for advanced recycling which was
a bill that passed last year yes and
that is exactly the Genesis of this bill
which speaks to the question that
misunderstanding in my
original presentation is that we don't
have any advanced recycling facilities
that are looking to be permitted
that is that's what I'm talking about
not okay restaurants so thank you but I
I think if I understood the the course
of the of this Legislation during
discussions at enr in the Senate
um with some input from Des I think it
was sort of recognized that rather than
just do a set of regulations that
focused in isolation on one industry it
really would make a lot more sense for
the public health of the people of New
Hampshire to look more at at when you're
licensing a facility and I don't really
mean a restaurant's grease trap I'm
thinking of a landfill just comes to
mind or something like that rather than
looking at these things in silos it
makes a lot more sense rather than
whether it's Solid Waste or air or water
to look at it in more Global Way and
I don't know if it was Senator avard who
introduced the amendment that that
changed this I thought it was but I mean
the idea is that you shouldn't be
viewing potential sources of damage to
Public Health in isolation but more
globally and just to continue Mr chair
it seems to me that all this is is
really a scoping study to see if we
couldn't do a better job of of
um licensing facilities and when you're
doing this you would ice you would
identify the facilities you wanted to
apply to there would probably be some
public input in your process you just
said that you would have some sort of a
task force you'd be working with and
then you'd make recommendations and no
regulations and no legislation would be
passed
by anybody until you made your
recommendations so the so the I mean
rather than have a legislative study
committee do this that doesn't have
professional background this would be
something that you would take on at the
agency level the ultimate goal being the
public health of the people of the state
represents Sweeney thank you Mr chairman
I have I'll have several questions I
think my first question is historically
on environmental issues in the state
when it comes to permitting licensing do
we hire somebody for a temporary
two-year scoping study to perform the
study or do we have a legislative
commission study the impacts and the
potential
future regulations
I'm not really sure how to answer that
question I'm I can't I don't remember
the last time we've gone down this
particular path
um I think the reason
we're looking at a new position here is
that if if it's decided we want to look
at this it was just a recognition that
we don't have the bandwidth right now in
the department to do this work
whether that's in the air division Water
Division or waste division follow-up
sure thank you so considering that you
currently don't have the bandwidth to
study what you would Define as communal
cumulative impact analysis
at the end of the day in in two years if
there's a list of regulations that were
presented to the legislature to adopt
what would the bandwidth required be for
Department of Environmental Services to
enforce those regulations on the
permitting process as it stands would
you need 10 more additional staffers in
three years 20 more I don't think we
know to be honest with you I mean I
think we would probably Envision this
would be initially started as a
temporary position it could likely
become a permanent position in the
future
depending on what comes out of the
scoping study
um and obviously anything that comes out
of that in terms of potential regulatory
reforms or changes the department would
have to evaluate how to do that and what
resources would be necessary at that
time thank you I mean as I said before
this is somewhat of an unknown in terms
Ms Sweeney I would like to also answer
uh your question is that we we don't
have anyone who looks at the cumulative
impacts but we we do have
um a federal agency starting to look at
these cumulative impacts so we would
like to be in charge of our own destiny
here and bring our department in their
different silos and divisions that they
have right now to have this
um this position be able to facilitate
bringing that information all together
particularly as stated in the
legislation as it relates to Public
Health and that is some of the places
where we have had some significant
legislative legal
issues in this day particularly with
pfas and Benzene so we need to be
looking at the cumulative impacts of the
public health on
future places that are facilities going
in which we're not doing right now so
you know this is us taking control of
our our own space and our own
information
representative Deanne McGuire thank you
Mr chairman you said that this is kind
of a new area in that no other states
are really doing it yet the federal
government is just looking at it and so
on
so how are you going to be able to hire
someone with any kind of experience
who's able to do this task
that's obviously a great question I
wouldn't say
no other State's done anything there are
several states that we're aware of that
are currently looking at this I know the
state of Massachusetts I know we all
don't love Massachusetts but they they
have a legislative directed to look at
this and
where they chose to look first was
within their air program and in
particular they are our toxics program
they're currently about 18 months into a
two-year process to look at potential
changes to their program
I believe the state of Minnesota has
looked at cumulative impact so we would
go out there and look to see what has
been done in this area I think we feel
like we could hire somebody with a good
skill set that could do that type of
work
can you give us any example of some
environmental mishap
that has been occurred because we do not
currently
have this kind of Regulation is there is
there something
going on wrong somewhere that so all I
can talk about is the way our current
program let me just oh
we didn't request DS didn't request the
original Bill the amended Bill we had
concerns with the original bill
the new bill that came out of the Senate
the department was neutral on but that
clearly took the position of if the
legislature feels we want to go down
this road we need the resources to do it
um and I forgot representative what was
your specific question I previewed that
give me an example of got it you know
somebody built this yep and and it was
permitted because it followed all the
rules but but it turned out to be a
disaster because that so right probably
an easy example I could give you in the
air world because that's where I reside
is
under our current statute RSA 125i we
regulate air toxics in New Hampshire we
have health-based standards for over 600
compounds
sources under the statute and the rules
need to demonstrate that they comply at
their property boundary for those
individual pollutants on a gluten
specific basis
it does not require the department to
look at if there's another facility
located next door emitting the same air
toxics we don't take that into
consideration we only look at the
individual Source at the property
boundary
another thing we do currently do is we
regulate those 600 compounds on a
compound by compound basis in theory
under this what you could require
sources to look at would be I emit
compound one I meet that standard I emit
compound two I meet that standard but
what's the interaction between those two
compounds and how do you look at that
from a regulatory standpoint so I can't
necessarily say there's a failure but I
can say is there are certainly
limitations to the existing program as
to how we review it and that's the type
of question we get from the public when
we have public hearings what about that
interaction
and that's a very simple
as air comparison
is not necessarily a comparison of
potential I breathe one compound this
way I drink something in my water this
way what's what's the impact of those
two together so
representative grassy please followed by
representative Weiler now just uh
listening to what you've been talking
about one of the comments was one of the
questions was asked about Staffing from
what I'm hearing you saying is that once
you get this all developed this would
become part of what are the current
review standards that you have and so
that the reviews would be done by
Staffing that you currently have this
would just be a different way of looking
at it or maybe some additional things
you have but you wouldn't need another
whole group of people to go out and do
inspections just on this it would become
part of your standard review process you
may keep one person on to keep the
standards going but you know and improve
the standards but as far as inspections
I don't think you're going to be looking
at doesn't seem to me from what you're
saying that you're going to need any
additional people
I don't know I can definitively say that
I I will sit here and say because this
is a scoping study and we don't know the
ultimate outcome of this
there could be those impacts down the
road I I just I don't know until you go
through the process I don't know what I
don't know at this point I have to admit
representative Grant oh I'm sorry
representative when I respond to
representative grassy and referencing
back to representative Evil's question
that
um the original bill was not I was
asking for an opportunity to participate
in some rule making and it has
subsequently evolved into this scoping
study because
it was we don't have the information on
cumulative impacts in order to make
any kind of appropriate rules so this
scoping this person is going to be doing
that evaluation to see what what might
we want to consider there is no
legislation that is coming out of this
this is a specific
role within Des so we don't have any
legislation on deck that this is hoping
to bolster we don't have any rules on
deck that this is hoping to bolster we
don't have any legislation or rules that
we are hoping this position will get rid
of that is not the what this is about
this is about taking those
specifics um
pieces of Des and being able to have one
person look at the cumulative impacts
from each of those divisions on the
I still think this this leads to overly
short-term thinking
having watched some of the issues for at
least 50 years and I can remember the
development of Peace Air Force Base and
the nuclear power plant in Seabrook and
all the horrors that we were told to
expect from those developments all the
dangers anybody within 10 miles of that
nuclear thing was going to be fried and
all this kind of thing and now
here's the cumulative effects
big increases are in economy and both of
the Two Towns affected by those
developments pay about a third of the
property taxes that all the rest of us
pay so there's sometimes cumulative
effects that are positive but on the
short term would have been turned down
and there was a big move to do that so
we've got to realize that you know we
can't always standing be standing a
thwart progress and saying oh that might
be a problem that's what this reminds me
of
represent people
um thank you Mr chair so it it strikes
me that the reason that the Senate uh
proceeded down this path and the reason
that Ena recommended this 19-0 and the
reason that everybody voted for it on
the house floor is that this is an
incremental step to to sort of
understand better how to protect the
public health in the in these areas
where these facilities are being
licensed I mean so many times you might
see uh legislation just introduced that
would call Deep call on Des to just
regulate cumulative impacts period this
was an incremental step that
for people to look at whether it made
sense to do it this way and to actually
put money where our mouth is and finance
the Des to look at it itself they are
the experts I mean another way to do it
is a legislative study commission but it
seems to me this really would put it in
house it in the agency that is
responsible for doing these things and
to me this just seems like a logical
approach I'm actually kind of horrified
that we don't look more cumulative at
facilities that are being licensed that
are potential sources of pfas or pcbs or
so I just have a quick question
following up on representative ebel's
comments why wasn't a commission
considered and I think back of
Representative evil was on a commission
dealing with solid waste and then this
division heard testimony and saw
legislation that we supported to provide
some staffing based on the
recommendations of this commission where
you could have someone from the planning
Community des and put some money aside
but not necessarily two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars but to get a
broader input from the public with a
commission versus just having someone
centered at the department to look at
this
let's go
um thank you for asking for the Genesis
of this
um and to be to be clear
hiring this person at DES to look across
the agencies and across all of um
the air water soil and look at Public
Health
that first of all that would be a
fascinating commission however
um we felt that public health
deserved a person who works in this
field full-time and that we could use
the item the expertise that we have at
DES and bring in someone who already
does this kind of a value evaluative
work again we're not Reinventing the
wheel we're not coming up with something
that other states aren't already doing
this is actually something that many
many states are evaluating right now
so that's why we want to do that do this
in this way and also
um again there's no legislation coming
so we don't this is not a legislative
study commission about future
legislation we're looking at Public
Health impacts and some of the things
that we have seen the public health be
impacted by is only after the fact
like with pfas and with Benzene so
what we are trying to do is get in front
of that so that we can possibly create
our own rules and create our and that
would be the preference is to go through
rulemaking
so that we are protecting our Public
Health which either we protect our
Public Health we pay for it on the other
end this is a this is a preventative
measure
oh
thank you see no further questions the
division is a couple of things I'm sorry
representative Carol McGuire
thank you
um I'm really concerned that it just
says facility without any definition and
I'm
I don't know how to interpret that and I
don't know how the person who we would
get to do this study
um
we Des permits so many different kinds
of facilities under so many different
laws what which ones do you start with
where do you pick what's the what kind
of facilities are you talking about
regulating I mean if you're talking
about a power plant
that's one thing but you permit a whole
lot less significant items as well so
again this bill doesn't propose any
regulations nor is it asking nor is it
asking
um this person that's hired to propose
regulations that is not in the scope of
this bill this bill is to hire somebody
to study what the cumulative impacts are
in the areas of air water and soil
pollution it's like that's and studying
cumulative impacts is the bare basic the
bare basic right now we don't do that
I I I
appreciate your enthusiasm about the
subject but I think that this without
further definition of what on Earth this
person is going to be looking into you
have no idea what's going to come out of
it and because
yeah
and also this person is reviewing and
planning for the development of
definitions and standards as it relates
to cumulative impact
definitions and standards are what you
use to make laws and rules I mean they
will not be this person will not be
making the laws and rules but they'll be
giving us the framework that somebody
will be proposing laws and or rules on
otherwise why bother
if they say that our current unless this
person comes in and says our current
analyzes and requirements are perfect
there's nothing to worry about which I
would not believe I'd love to see that
happen but I don't believe it they're
going to come in with more requirements
and more regulations and we're going to
have to bring them into law or rules or
both
I'm very concerned that this is a giant
fishing Expedition for more
environmental regulations
representative evil has a question on
the ranking member representative
McGuire would like the Republican
Secaucus in the back room I just
wondered is facility defined in your
statutes or by regulation so I would I
would venture to Guess that regulated
facilities are Divine defined by Statute
by Statute or by rule by rule all right
I was trying to find it quickly and I
couldn't I mean there's not a single
definition of facility across the
department I mean we have
a number of licenses and permits that we
issue as an agency and the regulated
entity under each one of those programs
is defined within that program
and may I follow up on that yeah so this
I just noticed I mean this is not
statute law this is chapter law right so
this is a standalone thing it is not
part of air or part of water or
something like that right this is a
one-time stand-alone piece so it is what
yes
okay I believe uh emotion is going to be
offered by representative evil okay
um Mr chair based on the
based on the questions that are
revolving around the word facility and
other concerns that have been expressed
and maybe we'd have the opportunity to
look a little bit more into this
cumulative impacts issue I'd like to
make a motion to retain second
the most has been made by representative
Ebel and seconded by a representative
Dan McGuire to retain the bill and when
the clerk is ready if she'll please call
the roll right right I'm determined to
do it right this time representative
McGuire yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Carol McGuire
uh representative the clerk votes yes
chair Weiler
yes
and uh chair Leachman yes okay
Mr chair
one thing that
thinking about this it sounds like a PhD
project at say UNH in their
environmental Department it's it's not
something that you would
it's a major effort to identify
cumulative impacts particularly if
you're going to be going from one medium
to another
it it's a
I If This Were to be a legislative
commission I would vote strongly against
it because I wouldn't want to serve on
thank you everyone good to see you
remember tomorrow we do have an exact